вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі цього тижня з вами я ліс
шу війна на Близькому Сході збурює людей
і в Європі у великих містах багато
громадян виходять на вулиці проти
насильства близько 300 000 людей пройшли
Лондоном на пропалестинській
демонстрації вони закликали до негайного
припинення вогню і припинення
ізраїльських атак у газі у Парижі
близько 100 000 учасників протестували
проти зростання антисемтизму у Франції а
також закликали до єдності у протидії
ненависті до
євреїв багато людей покинули Ізраїль
через страх подальших атак серед них і
Мендель московіц він знайшов прихисток в
Угорщині де проживає одна із найбільших
єврейських громад у
Європі москові це його сім'я переїхали в
місце прямо на березі озера Балатон тут
вони та інші єврейські біженці можуть
оговти від жахливих подій на
батьківщині сцени спокою після хаосу
війни люди які прибувають з Ізраїлю до
цього притулку на березі угорського
озера Балатон кажуть що це знахідка Божа
це диво усередині лунають звуки
єврейської молитви в імпровізованій
синагозі діти співають пісні на
івриці а працівники кухні готують
кошерну їжу для 200 мешканців серед них
матерів які втекли до Угорщини після
нападів
хамасу моїм дітям було дуже страшно чути
вибухи це було справжнім
жахідттям Я мешкаю поруч із ліванським
кордоном Ми боялися що те що зробив
хамас вони зроблять із нами тому ми
евакуювались Вона вирішила приїхати до
Угорщини де проживає одна із найбільших
єврейських громад у Центральній та
Східній Європі місцеві жителі
перетворили цей колись занедбаний курорт
на центр для біженців після того як
минулого року Росія розпочала війну в
Україні
мендельмосковіц втік зі східної України
зі своєю сім'єю минулого року і знайшов
новий дім на півдні Ізраїлю Але минулого
місяця на його поріг знову пройшла війна
надто знайоме
відчуття Протягом всієї історії євреїв
евакуювали євреї виганяли з їхніх рідних
країн багато
разів і нажа є відомий вислів що історія
повторюється ми хотіли вірити що світ
став кращим ніж був
раніше але на жаль ми бачимо велике
зростання антисемтизму по всьому
світу Влада надає це місце асоціаціям
угорських та українських єврейських
громад без орендної плати і воно
ретельно охороняється але
антимігрантська риторика Угорщини не
змінилася люди тут вже мали право
відвідувати цю країну як громадяни
України Ізраїлю правий уряду Будапешті в
минулому вже неодноразово звинувачували
у розпалюванні ворожнечі та використанні
антисемітських висловлювань але сам уряд
запевняє що проводить політику нульової
толерантності до антисемітизму на
початку жовтня прем'єр-міністр Віктор
Орбан заборонив усі протести на знак
солідарності із палестинцями охрестивши
їх протерористичними
рабин сломкокевиш вважає що це допомагає
створити відчуття безпеки так я гадаю що
подібні демонстрації ні бути
заборонені Угорщина має певний рівень
антисемтських настроїв в
суспільстві на жаль як і більшість
суспільства у
Світі але тут майже немає фізичних
нападів на єврейські установи чи
фізичних актів
насильства але в той час як одні
почуваються в безпеці інші відчувають що
їх змушують мовчати цей невеликий
меморіал єдине місце куди бухгалтер
Рамадан мегарі може прийти аби висловити
своє горе і гнів дуже сумно що ти не
можеш говорити про те що у тебе на серці
або висловлювати свої емоції після
трагічних подій які ми пережили за
останні кілька днів для рамадана ця
трагедія особиста у своїй квартирі Він
показує нам фотографії втрачених
близьких які загинули у своєму будинку
під час масованих бомбардувань Ізраїлем
гази Я втратив тата маму сестру дідуся
скільки рідних ви втратили
загалом 22є з моїх близьких
родичів дуже сумно бачити ці фотографії
і знати що ти більше ніколи не побачиш
їх У
реальності і з кожним днем Гуманітарна
катастрофа в газі стає все більш
жахливою і Рамадан живе лише з однією
Надією просто продовжити життя з тим що
залишило
не зазнати більшої втрати на озері
Балатон жителі звертаються до віри коли
розбрат і страждання заважають бачити
хоч якесь майбутнє Ми сподіваємося і
молимося щодня щоб ця війна закінчилася
люди не хочуть цієї війни люди хочуть
жити в мирі мати сім'ї мати
друзів на березі озера туман війни
відчувається дуже далеким мендаль знає
що його сім'ї пощастило що вони знайшли
прихисток тут бо для багатьох інших
людей безпека все ще
недосяжна це стосується і Наталії
ольшанської з України Вона живе менш ніж
за 30 км від лінії фронту де українські
солдати ведуть запеклі бої проти росіян
вибрюючи кожен Метр і відвойовуючи нові
позиції особливо небезпечною ситуація
залишається на сході України досі
окупованому російськими військами
зокрема навколо Запоріжжя Де розташована
найбільша в Європі атомна
електростанція тим не менш Наталія
Ольшанська повернулася до рідного міста
вона хоче кинути виклик небезпеці і
почати відбудову і вона робить це заради
людей яких любить
найбільше кладовище біля Запоріжжя Тут
щодня з'являються нові
могили Наталія Ольшанська привела нас на
могилу свого
сина
Даня пішов у добровольчий батальйон Він
загинув коли російські танки атакували
його позицію Наталія приїжджала сюди
оплакувати його могилу щодня протягом
півроку і я
зрозуміла
згодом що Даня не хотів би бачити Мене
з
сльозами болем бо він був дуже
позитивний От і
я загрузила себе
роботою Наталія підприємиця у Запоріжжі
колись ідеальному соціалістичному
плановому місті що розбудовувалось у
сталінські часи через його центр
пролягає широкий
бульвар багато людей тут колись мріяли
про відновлення Радянського Союзу тепер
пояснює Наталія їхнє місто стало
символом опору російському
вторгненню Зараз ми бачимо наслідки
радянського цього
шовінізму великоруського починаючи від
відмови до
геноциду але Наталія впевнена що їм це
не вдасться у 2022 ро році коли
російські війська окупували цю територію
вони майже повністю знищили виробництво
Наталії на схід від Запоріжжя її сім'я
виїхала тепер коли до лінії фронту
всього 30 км Вона вирішила відновити
своє виробництво це не простий виклик не
в останню чергу тому що важко знайти
нових
[музика]
працівників заміщення відбулося
але тимчасово переміщеними особами і це
не ті люди які готові фахово працювати а
навпаки яким потрібна
допомога її маленький Сімейний бізнес
виготовляє органічні продукти серед
бестселерів джеми енергетичні батончики
та соки з кизилу фрукту багатого на
Вітамін
С за смаком він щось середнє між
крембрюле та маракуєю
кизил поширений в Україні його
традиційно використовують при застуді
пояснює чоловік
Наталії колись давно лікарі ходили
поселеннями і коли бачили що в цій
місцевості росте кизил то вони звідти
йшли бо вважали що там де росте кизил
люди не хворіють і лікарі тут не
потрібні із часом подружжя сподівається
експортувати свою продукцію але поки що
їм доводиться зосередитися на тому щоб
стати на ноги в Україні
зменшились продажі багато людей не мають
грошей продукція в нас преміум-класу Та
вонамі вона не дешева навіть коли сирени
повітряної тривоги виють по кілька разів
на день їхні працівники залишаються на
робочих місцях зараз уже Ну
звикли дуже конечно переживаємо
але але тут не не хочеться покидати свою
країну Ми дуже ніколи не задумувались
над
над тим наскільки ми її
любимо свою
державу Вони часто переглядають старі
відеозаписи сім'я більше не може
дістатися до своїх колишніх садів на
схід від Запоріжжя шлях туди закритий
зубами дракона та мінними полями
розставленими
росіянами Даня загинув влітку 2022
року Сергій і Наталія присвятили йому
відновлення свого бізнесу вони планують
що колись їхня донька Ліза очолить
компанію Мій брат взагалі загив
24 але це нас
навчило при будь-яких умовах жити
сьогоднішнім днем за 30 км від нас люди
гинуть і там відбувається справжнє пекло
пекло на землі
і ти починаєш цінувати кожну хви
почати все спочатку у Запоріжжі після
всього що пережила їхня сім'я буде
нелегко кожна думка і дія затьмарюється
війною та постійною тривогою через
атомну електростанцію яка знаходиться
Всього за 50 кме від
містаця тема то то загострюється ця тема
то спадає напруга тому що інших тем дуже
багато у нас лінія фронту за 25
кні і місто
прифронтове більшість людей які вразливі
виїхали залишилися тільки
найстійкіші Наталія приїжджає сюди
якомога частіше щоб набратися нових сил
тут дух сили і волі
козацтва тому я дуже часто сюди
приїжджаю для того щоб
відчути чим дихали сильні люди
характерники воїни які були
непереможні непокірні козаки які понад
усе цінували свободу Це її спадщина каже
Наталя і вона цілком може бути джерелом
натхнення для духу опору який живе і
процвітає у
[музика]
Запоріжжі люди вирощують свиней тисячі
років цієї особливої породи не було б
якби фермер ултер уланд не розгледів
потенціал який вона має особливо що
стосується її смакових якостей уленд
володіє свинофермою на сході
Німеччини прямо на території колишньої
німецької Демократичної Республіки у
селі гімріц у Саксонії ангальт і історія
колишньої східної Німеччини тісно
пов'язана з історією свиней
уланда відгодівельна свиня лейкома
Приречена на коротке життя але Ця порода
ледве не зникла зовсім разом із коли
німецькою демократичною Республікою саме
у цьому регіоні з його родючими грунтами
розводили свиней породи лейкома Ця
порода все ще існує завдяки волтеру
уланду але він швидше за все останній її
селекціонер на його фермі щороку
народжується близько 2 потисяч поросят
лейкома ми відвозимо їх на відгодівлю в
сусіднє село за 10 де Вони залишаються
наступні 10 чи 11 місяців поки не
досягнуть ваги 180 кг тоді вони будуть
готовими до
забою зрештою це їхня доля лейкома - це
абревіатура від лейпцига кодбуса і
магдебурга трьох східнонімецьких
регіонів де були виведені ці
свині на ось таких фабрично-заводських
фермах та від івельних базах 170 000
свиней утримувалися у тісних загонах із
автоматизованим
годуванням передусім для прибуткового
експорту свинини на
захід але тут не обійшлося без перешкод
свиня лейкума не була добре
пристосованою до таких умов
[музика]
розведення вони індивідуалістичні вперті
і своїми думками умови таких великих
примі були нелегкими для цих тварин і
кожній свині доводилося боротися щоб
вижити Але перед тим як усе дійшло до
ладу на фермах усій НДР А разом із нею і
лейкомській свині прийшов
кінець західні породи були більш
прибутковими об'єднана Німеччина
практично дозволила породі лейкома
вимерти але з Нідерландів приїхав Волтер
уланд який розгледів потенціал цих
східнонімецьких
свиней на його фермі у сільській
місцевості Саксонії ангальт лейкумам
дозволяють виходити на свіже повітря у
будь-яку
погоду це витривалі
свині і вони набавто краще пристосовані
до сучасного вільного вигулу ніж
високопродуктивні звичайні
свині густа щетина захищає шкіру цих
свиней від сонця рано вранці у Берліні
тривають наступні етапи
[музика]
виробництва цей м'ясник преміум-класу
один із постійних клієнтів Уолтера
уланда Сьогодні він приймає партію боків
свинини породи лейкома цим чоловікам
доводиться не абияк
потрудитися вони важчі з інших свиней а
ці особливо важкі це дуже великі
шматки на їхніх ребрах багато жиру і
м'ясо виглядає не так як у
супермаркеті м'ясо лейкоми від природи
має темніший колір у наш час більшість
звичайної свинини насправді більше схоже
на курячу
грудку м'ясник Маркус бенцер переконаний
у перевагах породи лейкума а також у
рішенні східної Німеччини розводити
[музика]
її НДР намагалася відродити класичну
фермерську
свиню тому що вони усвідомлювали те що
усвідомив і я що традиційні методи не
дуже добре працюють із сучасним
промисловим
тваринництвом люди люблять чути що в НДР
все було
погано але я можу сказати що це було
дійсно хороша ідея дійсно хороша
ініціатива
уланди також продають продукцію зі
свинини породи лейкума у своїй
фермерській
крамничці за вищими цінами ніж у
звичайних
супермаркетах утримання цих тварин
обходиться дорожче ніж за часів НДР але
цим селекціонерам не цікаве фабричне
фермерство це жахливо Ми не повинні їсти
м'ясо щодня якщо ми їстимемо його трохи
менше це буде краще і для клімату і для
довкілля і для
тварин Якби я був змушений Посадити їх у
загон і запакувати їх так само щільно як
тоді мені б довелося
закритися Я б не став вегетаріанцем та
більше не отримував би задоволення від
розведення
свиней із ніжним дотиком до жорсткої
свині Саме так ултер уланд хоче
продовжувати своє тваринництво навіть в
умовах демократії і в часи зменшення
спожи
мяса у середньому жінки живуть довше за
чоловіків але ці британські пані не
хотіли старіти на самоті тому взяли
ситуацію в свої руки і створили
спеціальний житловий проект у північному
Лондоні мешканки мають відповідати двом
вимогам це повинні бути жінки і їм має
бути більше 50 років і з роками це місце
стало домівкою для справжньої спільноти
І глибокої дружби
насолоджуючись повсякденним життям разом
хеді арджент і Шарлота Балаш люблять
зустрічатися у своєму спільному
саду ми всі поділяємо Це бажання бути
частиною спільноти І знаєте особливо
коли ви досягаєте мого віку Я вже не так
часто виходжу кудись гуляти Це не для
всіх але я думаю що це чудово для мене
це прекрасно 26 жінок старших за 50
років живуть у кохаузингу newграound у
північному Лондоні кожна з них має
власну квартиру але у спільній вітальні
завжди є Із ким поспілкуватися у свої 94
роки хедді аржент найстарша тут вона
приєдналася 12 років тому коли помер її
партнер я точно не хотіла переїжджати в
якийсь дім
пристарілих і в той же час я розуміла що
мої доньки будуть переживати що я весь
час буду сама
мене турбувало що мої доньки
хвилюються і я подумала що настав час
узирнутися і пошукати якийсь
альтернативний спосіб життя має щось
бути знадобилося 18 років щоб це бачення
невеликого житлового масиву нарешті
стало реальністю засновницям довелося
боротися з багатьма бюрократичними
перепонами а також із хибною думкою що
така велика кількість літніх людей в
одному містці може перевантажити
соціальні служби та служби
догляду уникаючи ізоляції підтримуючи
одна одну Я думаю що ми мабуть А якщо
чесно то точно стали меншим тягарем для
соціальних служб ніж були б якби кожна з
нас жила сама по собі
хеді аржент може легко заскочити в гості
до своєї сусідки Хіларі вернон Сміт
художниці обох жінок заспокоює
усвідомлення того що хтось завжди поруч
якщо їм потрібна
[музика]
допомога я думаю що з віком якщо я хочу
допомагати іншим людям то мені буде
трохи легше допомагати жінкам ніж моїм
друзям-чоловікам і жінкам набагато
частіше потрібне таке житло коли вони
стають старшими ніж чоловікам адже в
моєму поколінні саме жінки зазвичай
живуть довше ніж
чоловіки тож частіше залишаються
самотніми чоловікам тут звісно раді але
тільки як
відвідувачам у нас багато відвідувачів
чоловіків у нас є брати є онуки знаєте У
нас є садівники теж чоловіки тож навколо
нас багато чоловіків але вони не можуть
тут
жити життя лише із жінками приваблює
багатьох Ширлі гурвіч уже за 60 і вона
нещодавно подала заявку на квартиру але
на неї є довгий список очікування вона
не бачить у правилі без чоловіків
проблеми Якщо хтось починає зустрічатися
з кимось на серйозному рівні то як і в
будь-яких стосунках у вас виникає це
питання де ми будемо
жити Ці жінки пишаються спільнотою яку
вони створили Вони повністю
самоорганізовані усі рішення тут
приймаються колективно без ієрархії
[музика]
коли вас 26 знаєте іноді важко почути
думку кожного важко досягти
консенсусу зрештою ви можете говорити
про дуже маленькі речі які здаються
дріб'язковими у спільноті вони часом
стають дуже
важливими навіть якщо іноді буває важко
Ці жінки вважають себе новаторками і
сподіваються що інші посліду їхньому
прикладу спільнота замість нудьги
підтримка замість
ізоляції кожна з нас дуже відрізняється
від інших І це чудово але всіх нас
об'єднує бажання бути частиною
спільноти дбати одна про одну не
наглядаючи одна за
одною Саме так хочуть жити подруги хедді
арджент і Шарлота
Балаш самовизначеними і незалежними
глибокої
[музика]
старості одна з речей яку я люблю в
цьому шоу - це те що час від часу ми
показуємо вам найбожевільніші змагання
які проводяться в
Європі зараз сезон гарбузів і в Бельгії
ці гігантські овочі використовують не
лише для приготування супів та прикрас
на Хелловін У маленькому містечку
кастерлі знають що гарбузи можна
використовувати набагато
веселіше
і тепер вони всі заслужили трохи
смачного гарбузового супу аби зігрітися
а на цьому Ми завершуємо тижневий випуск
Європа У фокусі підписуйтесь на наші
соцмережі щоб дізнатись більше історій з
усього континенту Дякуємо за перегляд і
до наступної
зустрічі
[музика]